[Music]
let's go to
chelsea in columbus ohio what's up
chelsea
hi how are you so good how are you
i'm well thanks um so my question today
is
how do i build confidence while dating
um
and some backstory to that is that i am
31 but i have cerebral palsy i walk
independently with no assistant devices
or anything like that
but i just struggle in this one area
of life and i don't know how to fix it
okay so tell me
like tell me about you what do you do
where are you from where'd you grow up
i'm from ohio i work for the state
commerce um compliance department
i oh that's just a barrel of monkeys
it's fun i really like it my my team is
really cool did you know that did you
know in the history of the english
language no one has ever uttered the
sentence you just uttered
the compliance in whatever whatever
department is fun and i like it no one's
ever said those words ever you're like
shakespeare now that's fantastic no
that's awesome i'm glad i'm so glad you
love your your work man my buddy works
for in compliance for the government and
he loves it and i would rather set my
face on fire just to see if i can still
feel things and so good hey somebody has
to do that i'm so grateful for you um
how'd you get this job how did you get
into it
i well that's funny too my degree is in
healthcare administration but
right before the pandemic i just decided
to try something new
started applying for different jobs and
ended up in this agency i had worked for
other
agencies that were more dealing with the
public
before that and then just kind of
stumbled upon this because i
met somebody who worked in this
department at a meeting and just kind of
liked what they had to say so i
applied for the job and got it have you
ever seen the matrix
no
well
there's a scene in the matrix just
google dodging bullets
when uh keanu reeves leans back and the
bullets fly by him that's what you just
did with code by getting out of public
health
30 minutes before the whole thing went
down good for you man
it's so true
where'd you grow up
um columbus i still live where i grew up
in the same town
you said that like you failed something
do you want to go somewhere else
no i just that's all i've ever known all
right i just like it i like it i like
this in my hair between it and
you know i my friends are here and i
have a big i have a
big friend group here that i really like
and
so good all right so you're delightful
um thank you i work with a lot of mean
pushy people
just kidding kelly's nice she's nice um
but you sound delightful so tell me
about this dating mess
so i i really didn't even know that i
had a problem i i have a core group of
friends that i would say there's like
eight couples that go out constantly and
then there's me so i always joke that
i'm everybody's girlfriend
and you know we go out and it's like i
never feel like the third wheel i never
feel
like i'm not part of the group because
they've just always made me feel that
way
and
one of our waitresses one time that we
regularly get she said i couldn't figure
out who you were dating because you walk
in on somebody else's arm all the time
because we always hold hands as we walk
so that i don't fall
and things like that and she said it's
just funny she said they just love you
and i said i know
and um i won this kindness award at work
and i sent it in the group chat and i
got all kinds of um you know
congratulations and all that
and then one of my best friends he said
chelsea you're the only one who doesn't
get to experience your own kindness
you're not kind to yourself and i wish
that you were and i said oh i never
really thought about that
he said you're so kind to everybody else
i've been in 17 weddings
just yeah so i don't i don't have 17
friends that's
incredible no it's great my closet is
full of these dresses i refuse to get
rid of but it's it's great and it's a
little expensive but hey you know it's
like one of those things like i i don't
struggle when it comes to building
relationships but i struggle
when it comes to dating because i just
don't feel like
i'm the one someone's going to choose i
always
say i think god blinked when he made me
but only in the dating area
it doesn't make any sense like no it
does it does it does it does you're not
crazy okay
um and my one my one promise on this
show i'm gonna get answers wrong i might
get this one wrong but my promises
always tell the truth okay
and
um
here's i know this
that kindness often
um
people who are very very kind are often
very very lonely too
is that fair uh yeah
and yeah there's there is a relational
lonely and you've got you're surrounded
by people right there's a proximity to
loneliness you're surrounded by people
um who are sound like they're amazing
like that's you you won the lottery when
it comes to that
and then there's that
see that's awesome
then there's emotional loneliness
where i can be in a crowded room
surrounded by people who love me and
that i love and i feel completely and
totally alone
because nobody knows
i would do anything
for someone to be
looking me up and down right now i would
do anything for someone to squeeze my
hand under the table
right and i'm not going to say that out
loud because i want to bring everybody's
room down because i'm kind
and all these folks in here are really
nice and so i'm not going to i'm going
to make sure oh they're so good right
you know what i'm saying is that you
uh-huh
yeah it's hard for me to admit that but
it's like you hit the nail on the head
there
so
when's the last time you spoke out loud
here's what i want
and here's what i need and here's what i
don't have
because you're somebody who
sees yourself as broken
you see yourself as less than so much
that you even blame god for like ah he
whiffed on the on the assembly line
and
that's how you see yourself
and
the people around you don't see yourself
that way
but they
you when they when they don't see you
that way you put imaginary things in in
the mix
have you ever said these words well
they're nice to me because i've got
cp
or they invite me out because they don't
want me to be lonely because they're
nice
no well no they
my friends
they've been around for so long but they
don't even see it anymore like it's just
a natural thing and i want to get to
that point with somebody
in the dating
situation too and i know that i can get
there but i just i sabotage it before it
even starts
oh he doesn't like me
so have you ever had have you ever had
somebody be ugly to you dating
or something weird or okay tell me about
that
so i
tried like the online thing and so
because that's how everybody meets
people nowadays and so i noticed that
when i would mention it up front
they would become very sympathetic and
just
and they wouldn't want to just go away
they'd want to talk about it but they
weren't interested in dating anymore but
then when there was one time that i
didn't mention it and i met them in
person and his reaction even though it
didn't i don't think it was his fault
but it was extremely poor because he was
so distracted by what he didn't realize
what he was getting into or something
you know so he was just so distracted by
that that he couldn't see me for who i
was so it wasn't a productive date by
any means and he just wasn't his
reaction wasn't kind
i'll leave it at that but
it was very unkind so chelsea
he was an ass not you
right
yeah
his reaction was his poor reaction it's
not a reflection of some shortcoming you
have
you're different and you're unique is
that fair
which which cp do you have like which
cat which bucket is it in
it's
like a electricity
[ __ ] okay so and you say you just is
it one
lower
been body my legs okay
so when when somebody hears that on an
online chat
i've got cerebral palsy
a
most people don't know what that is
b
they're gonna google it and get
to webmd and we all know like i got a
headache well you could probably because
you have a brain tumor and you're gonna
be dead in 48 hours right so yes
when somebody gets that online they
don't have a context for it okay and i'm
gonna like i'll give them grace for that
you know what that means you know what i
mean i don't know what that i don't even
know what that is
um
i don't know
i i don't think you owe somebody that up
front
i also would much rather you meet
somebody in person because you're a
delightful human being and you're
surrounded by cool people
thank you it feels like is is dating
feel safer online because you're afraid
of someone
being an idiot to you
no i hate online i really do i hate it
can i be super super honest with you
yes
my guess is before this crew maybe
you've been been around forever
but
you've got a lifetime of people side
eyeing you
and or snickering or feeling exposed as
you walk through the mall or you walk
through an airport yeah
and that baggage comes with you every
time you reach out to connect with
somebody
and what it that that
those bricks in your backpack for lack
of better analogy that stuff that's
happened those side eyes those little
bitty things have been a pebble in your
backpack pebble in your backpack some
idiotic [ __ ] said something to you in
fourth grade because they were nine
and they threw a cinder block in your
backpack you've probably got those
stories right
or some well-meaning
goofball at your church whatever has has
happened
and
all the evidence
now
points to
you are
wonderful
so much so that people would rather hang
out with you than have a romantic
rendezvous alone that's how cool you are
that's how fun you are to have around
you know what i mean even the
the waitress at the at the bar y'all
frequent think you're some kind of
player dude because you got a new dude
every time
you know what i mean well i walked in
with the girls too she wasn't sure
hey dude she's she thinks you are
you're
yeah you are playing across the field
right so
here's the thing the evidence in your
life suggests
that people love connecting with you
and so the own
and this is hard because there are
idiots and you experience them there are
people that don't know what to say or
they think they know what to say and
they say the wrong thing that are
uncomfortable around
um physical differences or
they've never been around people who
aren't fully able-bodied all those
things happen
and so there will be some grace on your
part and you probably have a pretty good
radar when someone's being an idiot or
they just don't know and someone's being
a jerk
right i mean you're pretty savvy yeah
right you can tell like don't say that
i've got friends in my life my best
rental planner is a paraplegic
i've had other people who are not able
body come up and be like yeah that may
be funny for y'all because you all know
each other for 40 years don't say that
ever in public right and so you know
when someone's being a jerk or someone's
and your friends probably get away with
stuff too right and if they're your real
friends they should okay good
um
here's what i want you to remember
that if somebody
rejects you makes a comment does
something dumb
because of your differences
that's a sign that they are less than
not you
okay
and the only way forward
is for you to take a risk
and my promise to you is you're gonna
get hurt doing this
and
my promise to you is it's the only way
you're gonna finally let some of those
walls down
that bridge that gap from friend to
no you're the one i've been looking for
and the only way to make that bridge is
for you to take a risk
i'm willing to do that
and what i'm telling you is
it's um
you're worth that risk
thank you and walking around
walking around shielding yourself from
your heart from love
man you're not protecting that guy
that's going to get suckered into
falling in love with somebody who is
deficient
you're just going to keep yourself from
true connections in that way
don't do that to chelsea you're my
friend don't do that
is that fair
yes i appreciate that okay yeah so
moving forward here's the task i want
you to get with your friends
and i want you to do do you uh watch the
office
yeah do you remember that time michael
scott comes out and he's like i declare
bankruptcy and they were all like yes
that's not really how that works
remember that that's gonna be you and i
want you to get with a core group of
five or six or ten people
and say chelsea's officially on the
prowl
and i'm gonna take risks
because i want romantic connection
period
and my guess is they'll all cheer for
you and be like oh thank god i've got
so-and-so or they may not
but i want you to declare it say it out
loud okay
okay
protecting your needs and protecting
what you want from everybody else is not
kind
it's dishonest okay
so start telling people what you
actually need and what you actually want
and you can tell them i love hanging out
with you of course i'm coming out
but if i see him
i'm leaving you guys
you're gonna have to uber yourself home
because right you know what i mean
yeah
hey are you worth it
i well i hope so i think i am no chelsea
i am yes
yes
yes
and there's somebody who is
dying
for a hilarious
kind
fun
open
woman like yourself
i
no
hope
gonna find them no
hey if you will just be still and open
your heart up
y'all will find each other
they're not hiding from you somewhere
and you're going to get hurt and there's
going to be idiots and there's going to
be people who say the wrong thing and
they don't really mean it but that i
didn't mean to say it like that i meant
to say it like this and just so you know
that happens in non-able i mean in fully
able-bodied relationships too
the number of times i've said a thing
and i didn't mean to say it like that
with my wife oh gosh a lot
a lot okay
i want you to begin walking through life
seeing yourself that if somebody has the
opportunity to be with you they've won
the lottery
not they're settling for less than
okay
okay do you promise that
i will i will i promise okay homework
assignment tonight two things number one
you're gonna get the gang together it
doesn't have to be tonight but you're
gonna call and get them together and say
i'm making a declaration
number two
you are going to write chelsea a letter
tonight
okay
and that letter is going to be one of
strength
and sexiness
and laughter and here's what i bring
and here's where i'm strong and here's
where somebody would be the luckiest
freaking guy on planet earth to have me
and yes i walk with a limp and they're
gonna have to hold my hand big freaking
deal
right right
it's not a big deal
well then you quit making it
i know i'm trying to convince myself
when i say it out loud enough that it's
not no it's time that you get quiet and
write yourself a letter okay
okay because hey here's the deal it is a
big deal you have cerebral palsy it's a
big deal
it's not something to be minimized right
and
you're still lovable
why thank you
am i just saying that i don't i don't
you're like oh well thank you as though
i just complimented your wallpaper
okay cool
same team i yes yes we're on the same
team all right if you're really brave
i want you to write that yourself that
letter and i want you to mail it to me
okay
cool is that fair i will yep and if mean
things come out in that letter write it
all down get it all out there on that
paper okay okay
and i want you
to go back to what your buddy said
i want you to start treating chelsea as
though she's worthy of being loved and
she's beautiful and she's sexy and she's
funny and she's worth the romantic
relationship cool
yes because you're the one holding you
back right now and a whole cascade of
idiotic morons on the internet but ta-da
they're holding everything else back too
right
is that fair yeah
yeah
okay you are hands down one of the most
delightful people i've ever gotten to
talk to on the show and you're hands
down one of the bravest people you've
been navigating a hard hard row ahead of
you it's hard
and people don't get it
and
man
somebody is
talking about winning the lottery
talk about when to scratch off with you
it's gonna be pretty impressive
ah you're so great chelsea